and joining us now is House minority
leader Kevin McCarthy Congressman
welcome back glad you're with us
um you know I was the emcee the night
that Newt Gingrich became speaker it was
the first time in 40 years Republicans
took control of the house they kept and
they fulfilled their promise in their
case they had a contract with America
yours our commitments to America I've
urged Republicans to do this in the past
I'm glad you're doing this because
there's a there's a very strong
component of accountability here all of
your members that will run on these
commitments will they're pledging to
voters that they're going to keep them
correct
correct and you know Sean we're here I
wanted to roll out in Washington not
Washington D.C but Washington County
Pennsylvania why because the commitment
to America is about you America not
Washington and what we have is a plan
for a new direction we spent the last
year and a half all the Republican
members in Congress on different task
forces going out to listen to the
American public and if you watch the
rollout today that's exactly what we did
here we didn't get up and just talk to
you we took questions from the audience
how can we make this economy strong how
can we lower our gasoline price how can
we afford and stop inflation a nation
that's safe 200 000 new police officers
making sure these DA's and prosecutors
upholding the law our future that's
built on freedom that we have a parent's
Bill of Rights that you have a say in
your kids education I had a question
from uh she called herself a mama bear
that she'd gone to the school board
meeting because her poor daughter was
being left behind you know when she gets
called a terrorists we want you to have
a say in that and then how do we hold
this government accountable there is no
check and balance right now but we'll be
able to bring that we have a plan I know
the president attacked it last night I
guess he wants to attack it because much
of his policies created his problems and
he has no plan but we do and that's our
commitment to you if you trust president
majority join with president the
president has to attack because there's
no there's there's no policy success
that he can point to the worst inflation
in 40 years the highest gas prices we've
ever paid chaos We Now set a record of
illegal immigrants already this year we
got a long way to go over 2 million
illegal immigrants that we know about in
the country from one foreign policy
disaster after another
the American people this election what
are we now 47 days away 46 days away 46.
now the this is critical so much of this
depends on the economy and so much of it
is self-inflicted for example we can go
back to the Trump policies On the Border
you promise to do that they will work
they've been proven to work you can go
back to energy Independence that will
not only create high paying career jobs
it's good for National Security it will
lower the price of the pump and it will
lower the price of every item we buy at
every store and lower inflation why
would why did they abandon the single
best
um most independent uh thing that our
economy needs and that's the lifeblood
of our economy energy why did they just
stop domestic production
you know what on their very first day
they did this they went after all the
energy companies telling them to produce
less you know what that does that makes
us dependent on other countries why
aren't we going to be dependent on
America we're going to bring the supply
chain back from China we're going to be
energy independent which creates
American jobs it lowers inflation it
keeps more of your money in your pocket
as you go forward and you know the other
thing that it does Sean it makes the
world safer you know America energy
Independence also American natural gas
is 40 percent cleaner than Russian
natural gas so why don't we sell our
natural gas to Europe so they're not
beholden to Putin and others this is
just the start and we should secure our
border stop this fentanyl from coming
across and killing our children
you know you talk about you know four
big items with sub items in them
um the economy that includes energy
Independence fighting inflation strength
strengthening the supply chain you talk
about Safety and Security at our border
and every town and every city uh get rid
of these and say no bail laws refund the
police not defund the police increase on
National Security in light of all the
Hostile actors in the world uh you talk
about a future that is built on freedom
that starts with education uh but by
that I know you mean Reading Writing
Math Science History and computers not
uh woke this and woke that and CRT
we yeah we also ensure fairness that
only women compete in women's sports we
give you a parent's Bill of Rights we
want an education system that's focused
on children that teaches them to dream
big instead of what is happening today
we have a plan to catch our children up
from the Lost learning that happened to
the pandemic the Democrats have no plan
that's the difference we should have an
election based upon ideas we've laid out
a new plan the commitment to America the
president wants to attack it let him
attack it I challenge them to a debate
let's talk about his policies but what
the future can be with this commitment
and I promise you it's not about
Republicans this is about our country
that's why I need everyone who is
listening to join with us go to take
thehouse.com because Nancy Pelosi says
she's going to win seeds the D Triple C
says they're going to win seats no one
gives you a majority but this is a fight
not for the Republican party this is a
fight for our nation if you want an
economy that's strong if you want a
nation that's safe again in your streets
if you want a future that's built on
freedom and if you want to have some
accountability to your government this
is what's going to happen and Sean I
promise you this on the very first day
our very first bill is going to repeal
87 000 IRS agents because you know what
we work for you and it's not the other
way around a house minority leader Kevin
McCarthy we wish you luck thank you and
we're going to be talking to a lot of
the candidates running for the house and
the Senate
thank you Sean hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else